ماذا حل بها وبهم بعد تمرد الفاشل منتصف
شهر الماضي تطارد تساؤلات فاغنر وقادتها
ومقاتليها
منحوا ضمانات امنيه بموجب اتفاق حققته
البيلاروسيه لكنهم لم ياخذوا جميعا المسلك
ذاته فهل هي بدايه التشضي
ثمه اصحاب خيار البقاء اما للاندماج في
القوات النظاميه او العوده للحياه المدنيه
هم انفسهم من سلم موسكو اسلحه ومعدات
عسكريه شمل الدبابات وعظمه صواريخ واكثر
من 2000 طن من الذخيره وهم من اقترح
الرئيس الروسي قائدا جديدا لهم
يلقب بيدي الشعر الرمادي انه العقيد
المتقاعد
الذي شارك في حروب الشيشان وافغانستان
وسوريا
الفريق الاخر الذي اثر المغادره الى
بيلاروسيا مع قائد المجموعه
له اجنه مختلفه
غير بعيد عن الحدود مع اوكرانيا يطلع
هؤلاء بمهمه تدريب قوات الدفاع الاقليميه
يتعهد
بجعل الجيش البيلاروسي ثاني اقوى جيش في
العالم ويقول انما يحدث في اوكرانيا عار
يجب عدم المشاركه فيه
ومع ذلك فليس واضحا اذا كان دور الميليشيا
في الحرب على اوكرانيا قد انتهى ام انه
يتم الاعداد لفتح جبهه جديده في الصراع
ولم يتضح بعد ايضا مدى صحه تصريحات نائب
روسي قال ان الرئيس بوتين يحضر لهجوم على
بولندا بمقاتله فاجنر انطلاقا من
بيلاروسيا
ماذا الان عن مجمل عمليات فاغنر في الخارج
لطالما اتهمت المجموعه بتنفيذ ما وصفت
بمهمات قذره خلال مشاركتها في عمليات
قتاليه بمناطق نزاع في كل من افريقيا
واسيا وامريكا اللاتينيه منذ 2016 سجلت
نشاطات في ليبيا لدعم اللواء المتقاعد
خليفه حفتار كما انتشرت الميليشيا في
جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى وفي السودان منذ
2017 تحت غطاء شركات التنقيب عن الذهب كما
تنتشر في مدغشقر وموزمبيق وكذلك في مالي
بعد انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه منها والان لا
يخفي فرع المجموعه المتمركز مع قيادته
القديمه في بيلاروسيا بان العمليات
العابره للحدود ستستمر فان مقاتليه يرفعون
من جاهزيتهم كما قيل للتوجه حصرا الى
القاره الافريقيه